I'm leaving I'm gone no more for a week
I'm going to the UK this Wednesday I'll
be flying out to the UK join Jack and
Felix for a charity livestream full read
and if you don't know about read they're
an organization that is trying to fight
AIDS and hopefully eliminate it forever
so we're gonna be raising money for them
through our charity cringe myths which I
I don't exactly know what we're gonna be
doing but judging by the name pretty
much the same thing we always do in all
of our videos for engine controllably or
make you guys cringe
that's this upcoming week and I'll talk
more about that later in next week's
vlog but this past week was incredible
if you guys have been seeing some
snippets and some hints around here and
there you guys don't even know the half
of it Bob and Wade came into town and
from the second they got here from the
second they left we were non-stop making
videos like we pretty much recorded 19
videos worth of content maybe more
depending on how these videos turn out
because some of them we were just
messing around and we don't have any
idea how it's gonna go but a lot of them
were just really fun experiences like
Thursday last week we went out we hit
three different parks and we did three
different videos with you guys in these
parks just having fun playing games and
just being ridiculous the first one that
came out was actually the last one that
we did which was quick draw and this is
super fun because we were playing
pictionary in front of a big crowd of
you guys and it was just fun all around
because we all took turns doing things
well I mean we took turns you guys took
turns and then I was subjected to either
looking like a fool or looking like an
[ __ ] and it's just really fun to be
able to play games with you guys I just
hang out with you guys and make these
videos that combined the games that I
play you know here in my studio
quote-unquote studio my second bedroom
and you know combine that with going out
and meeting you guys and doing sketches
and doing challenges and just mixing it
all into a really fun recipe it's been
very hard to do because for one we've
been stockpiling a whole bunch of stuff
because one I'm going to UK and then two
we're all taking a big Christmas break
like for two weeks I mean the videos
aren't going to stop but we're still
trying to
pack them up and keep them going and
also at the same time keep them
interesting and thankfully we have been
doing that and I'm really proud of the
videos that we've been making lately but
with Bob and Wade here we also wanted to
try some new format stuff which
basically means we wanted to try to do
some improv games and most of what I do
is improvisational comedy in some aspect
or another like let's plays I'm making
[ __ ] up as I go along I don't have a
script it's not anything that I've got
predetermined in my head and so like we
love doing improv and we love learning
improv so we actually took to trying to
do improv in our day to day life so I'm
going to show you some videos where it
may work you know improv is a lot of
hit-or-miss
especially when you're doing it very
freeform and not very structured and
especially when you don't have a game to
talk about when you're doing it that can
carry on the experience when you're just
making [ __ ] up in your head I mean
who knows what's gonna happen but
sometimes it works and sometimes it
doesn't and we're trying to figure out a
way to make a good video about it that's
really funny because there's some really
funny moments here's a dildo for your
medical procedure Billy I'm fine
I just want to be a girl anything that's
the reason I got you to still though no
I'd rather have the money doesn't make
me a girl I need surgery change these
are goes
this is a lady girl test to you I don't
know cannot touch it no whoa so
basically the game that we were playing
is called change and you've probably
seen it in whose line is in any way or
whatever if you've ever been to an
improv show it's short form improv
basically you're doing the scene with
two random made up [ __ ] characters
and then somebody can yell change and
you have to come up with a new line to
dialogue and it's really hit or miss
because depending on what they come up
with is either absolutely hilarious or
completely fall flat on its face and
thankfully like each each scene is like
intermixed with just a few of these
elements and hopefully there's enough to
carry it through
but without like the proper guidance you
know you don't know if it can make a
funny actual video so it's equal parts
funny and equal parts cringy at times
but it makes for a a wholesome
experience as some might say but I won't
because it's not see we are in the
future man totally - let's look up
lottery ticket numbers and then go back
to the bathroom do they have that in
almanacs what's an almanac take are you
oh I forgot of it it's on back home [ __ ]
my house is already burnt down our house
the whole frat house whoa mom the frat
house bro it's our mom okay
all right wait no I forgot we did this
for a reason bruh we're gonna find out
the answers to math tests before we got
back we were gonna go to the Future to
see your daddy's jag we're gonna go the
future so we assassinate Hitler dude
you're totally right I know talk about
this in your fran chart I will not
molest the girls or the guys with really
big Hulu I don't have any testicles left
to give you you not see some man kids up
at it we're here if you use not bad just
stop but I like the weights cool reminds
me of what your mom sounded like less we
have the same mom oh yeah oh geez oh
geez yeah so you can see how it's
interesting in that you know we're not
experts at improv by any stretch of the
imagination we don't know what we're
doing and we're mostly just did this
because we wanted to learn and we want
to practice and we want to get better at
this because you know better improv
skills lead to better like just comedy
in general and make it for better videos
in general so we do these exercises so
that we can you know practice but we
don't know if it's actually gonna make a
video because there's really funny
moments in there and then there's really
not funny moments and it'd be kind of
awkward to lose context on the whole
scene if we were just cutting in between
everything because we only really have
this one camera angle and there's not
much you can do to cut in between it but
maybe we can make something like a
highlight reel out of the various videos
that we've done because there are some
really really funny moments like
Bob had some unbelievably funny moments
because Bob I've said numerous times bob
is the funniest guy I have ever met in
my entire life he is just the master of
comedy in our circle like everything he
says in every way that he says and we
did a don't laugh challenge and we were
all floundering but every time Bob came
up like he was the master ah [ __ ]
anyway he was just the master of making
everybody laughing and him every
opportunity and it was just so fun to
watch it was so fun to just watch Bob do
it and that's part of the reason why I
want to do these scenes is because Bob
was so funny
wanted to have children just like this
plane is sprouting you know what you
have to do to have children you have to
[ __ ] boy if you want to have kids take
me home and [ __ ] me oh then we did now
one that was really funny it was it was
another whose line game called literally
whose line where will you get bits of
piece of paper and if you may have
noticed we tweeted out and we asked for
random sentences this is what that was
for and it was for uh that means for us
see the darkness is consuming me I'm
tired and I want fisted a whole family
of go
[Music]
I just love the way that particular joke
Oh makes us left and it was so good it
was so cool it was so cool it was so
funny because when we were doing
quick-draw there was this little girl
there that literally went up to me was
like I have a joke ah Tyler and I have
NOLA she started to hate me I'm Tyler
joke ah
Tyler which if you don't know originated
from the seven second challenge what it
devolved in absolute [ __ ] towards
the end but kind of in the best way like
my god we love that video so much if you
haven't seen that video my god go us our
most recent 7 second challenge because
it was absolutely hilarious especially
at the end of the video oh man
and and it was just a lot of laughs like
that because when you're doing improv
with your friends it's so fun but maybe
you don't want anyone else to see it
because you don't know if it's funny but
we're hoping to build these skills so
that we can create like this group that
we can take out and actually maybe do
like a live improv show I don't know
when we're gonna get the skills to be
able to do that like we're learning from
if you know ninja Brian's wife Rachel
she is a absolute master of improv she's
incredible she's been doing it for like
eight years straight and she's a
professional teacher and I've seen her
in live shows and absolutely everything
she says
is hilarious so we're learning from her
when she has spare time to do it and
it's just so fun and also like I wanted
to mention that like we did do a lot of
Let's Plays just in general we got about
seven of them done we got seven Let's
Plays we got like seven challenges and
then five other miscellaneous videos and
more in case we actually make the improv
stuff into something so if you actually
want to see the improv stuff let us know
down in the comments below because we
want to do it and we want to go out and
do more things with you guys maybe not
even full meetups but just going out
into LA or taking road trips across the
country and just meeting you guys
wherever we go
and just recording videos about it and
making it something fun and interesting
and always keeping stuff on hand to be
able to do stuff with you guys and have
fun and and like that's what it's all
about it's about new ideas and trying
new things and being creative and
meeting you guys and just having fun in
a million ways and making a video about
it like that's what YouTube has always
been to me that's what I've always have
driven me to do more stuff is just this
idea that I can make absolutely anything
anything I want and all it takes is the
smallest idea and I can turn that into
something amazing and that's what's
really cool that was what was so fun
about this past week and that's why I'm
so excited to be able to show you guys
about it because we're gonna be editing
for a long time on making these videos
come to life and it's gonna take a while
to do it but when you see what we have
accomplished here it is going to be so
so fun and I cannot wait for you guys to
see it but it is coming very soon so
I'll let you guys know when I leave for
the UK and when I come back I'll
probably be documenting it all on social
media so check it out there Oh there'll
be pictures videos tweets whatever have
you I'll just keep you guys posted and
it should be fun I believe the
livestream is on Thursday but I'm not
armed sensor and maybe on Friday just
stay up-to-date about that and I will
let you know sooner if you guys know the
exact date I should know that but all I
know is that I'm gonna show up in London
and hopefully know where I'm going from
there so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye